crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though or I encyclia soccer
star JUCO above ground crew goes better
than most Jay Larson self-diagnosed go
download this week last week here we go
again [ __ ] the crab feast
ah yeah
ah welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday of the crap he's for
that hey the perfect pitch is a perfect
I mean come on better part of a lot of
pitch touches as they favorite ah great
to be here with the sickle cell before I
say anything before I say anything I
want to uh I let you say anything I
should say but I just really again want
to congratulate you in the invitation if
you haven't seen the move you got to go
see it JS all over your the [ __ ] in it
your best line whole [ __ ] movie
thanks man you gotta [ __ ] that's lying
oh [ __ ] a movie no doubt yeah it's you
know well the guys have righted her
comedic writer they were on the proud
feast when we were down inside my
worries right Matt Phil super talented
dude so I was lucky because they you
know they knew I was a comedian so they
were like I got those lines the phone
line and their range is stupid from
boats or dom flux the ride alongs I mean
it's crazy that just an S on that to
survive anyway great to see you thanks
great to see you in person um let me
just say future nation Jay Larson calm
calm Jay Larson comedy on all social
media great to be here a couple dates
coming up tomorrow tomorrow will be the
comedy store a live stand-up show great
lineup and we still have a couple names
that are we're just waiting on
verification that they'll be there but
it's going to be a sick show and then
next wednesday i'll be at The Comedy
Store doing Nick Youssef show and then
i'm off to nashville for the two shows
on the 21st at zanies with Nick Thune
Rory Scovel and Nate bargatze which will
be great and then bridgetown second
third and fourth of June our live show
will be on the fourth I'm doing stand-up
on the second and third and then 622
albeit meltdown in LA and then dublin in
july 27 to 34 them london after that for
three days the sep tember first through
third i want to tell you guys a quick
story about how amazing Feaster nation
is my mother leaves me a message the
other day and she's like two things I
want to tell you one was about something
else this is the one that mattered I
mean they both are great but this one
she goes I'm at church and I don't even
know the story I think I don't haven't
told right
the coffee hour well I was you know so
one person said some about the movie and
then this another person was like so the
other day I'm calling delta for a flight
this is a woman in the most church and I
was trying to organize like my bags or
whatever I called Delta and I tell
they're like okay they're like okay we
have your reservation here like where do
you live ma'am and she goes I live in
Stoneham Massachusetts and the guy goes
stone you know JLR's come on dude listen
listen to this and she goes oh I don't
but I know his mother Susan and he goes
Sue's Larson best guest on the crap beat
got the voice on the other end of zone
of Delta Delta dude what's up dumb I
mean that Eastern nation if you hear
this episode loud and cry loud and proud
thank you also my guys right past the
fedex do the road [ __ ] all over the
package that I readily it's the best yet
that like there's a million we could say
this is job he doesn't know how
someone's gonna react and he just throws
it I just think it's fantastic you guys
are the best you're you're just aa man
couldn't be more proud that you're our
fans so thank you for that and thank u
delta i am a rewards member delta so man
why don't you hop in there and try and
jack me up get me up to platinum I don't
travel as much anymore sickle cell what
up Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook Ryan Sickler calm as Jays
mentioned The Comedy Store show is
tomorrow night unfortunately we were
moved from last week out of our control
nothing we could do but we obliged
because we're like that Bruce Lee said
be like water that's what we do we move
like water so tomorrow night May
eleventh 8pm we have Jen Kirkman we have
Steve Rannazzisi we have Brad Williams
confirmed she'll be another guest drop
and then it's going to be a great show
it's five bucks go to the crab feast
calm get your ticket also next week next
Tuesday live crab feast podcasts at the
Hollywood improv with Gareth Reynolds
and Steve Simone king of the black
Palace you I mean that's gonna be that's
gonna have some great flash podcast come
on out if you're in the LA area and as
Jay mentioned the lifecraft fees podcast
on june fourth at Bridgetown also be
doing stand up there the third and the
fourth and I want to give a shout out to
a fan named Joe your wife
adrianna I hope I'm saying Adriana right
reached out wanted to give you a little
shout out so this time I guess I never
see it cuz I'm old you say here and I
don't respond back or whatever but like
you're pretty active I just wanted to
say it's your birthday month and a happy
birthday man and your wedding dudes get
real is coming up so blanket on it you
can pick one or good luck with both Joey
uh fraud tickets Ryan Sickler calm and
the crab feast calm merch is still on
the site obviously you guys tear it up I
love seeing the tweet at us I love it
bridgetown when you show up in your
merch it's always great amazon is such a
huge help so thank you all for doing
that the premium apps are there they're
available any which way you want them
however you need them just click on the
premium app anyway you want a baby way
you need a facebook fan page itunes page
five star reviews are still killing it
you're better than anyone out there in
the game and speaking of better than
anyone out there in the game let's talk
about it texture dot-com back with us
today when it comes to magazines you
know what you like and with texture you
can get all the magazines you want in
one super convenient place I mean we've
worked with these guys before and the
thing that we've said we love about them
everyone is like binging on Netflix this
is your opportunity to binge on
magazines and you don't have to go buy a
magazine too pricey or and we know from
traveling anyone who travels knows first
of all if you're subscribing to
magazines no one's subscribing to
magazine anymore you're buying them
compulsively when you need them now you
can just get them all and have them
right on your tablet or on your phone
and it's pretty amazing texture app lets
you tap into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using your
smartphone or tablet breeze through
hundreds of your favorite magazines
including back issues and pick the
articles that interest you the most
texture has made it easy to find
articles you can care about not just to
read like you can get an article about
sports and Si and if it's related to
something else they're going to pop you
up a suggestion from a different
magazine altogether yeah it's Henry and
it's the there limitless let me just
tell you some of the magazines on there
for the ladies allure
me dwell Architectural Digest coastal
living clean eating I'm trying to eat
clean natgeo still on there I love this
one cosmopolitan latinas that's out
there population last seen potential a
teen is Maxim I mean any magazine you
need and I'll back issues to the track
is ridiculous thank you can share can't
you you can share it up to five devices
the best part textures officing our
listeners a free trial right now when
you go to texture calm backslash crab
feast you'll gain immediate entry to all
the top magazines including back issues
and bonus video khideo content that's
another thing you don't get that I'm no
magazine is popping a video that you
start been reading for free right now
when you go to texture calm backslash
crab feast texture calm backslash crab
feast touch a modern also back this week
be the envy of your group we've got the
inside scoop on where to get the latest
tech gadgets fashions in de corps for
your lifestyle it's all available a
touch of modern calm where you can find
that all with the best prices on the web
touch of modern connects directly with
top designers they have timeless and
unique products each item is hand
selected to grab your attention all the
best prices online anywhere guaranteed
I'm on their daily I'm always getting
stuff off of touch of modern i bought a
flashlight the other day that I swear to
God I could see stuff on the moon with
it was unbelievable I swear to God I was
ridiculous at a great your neighbors
like they're moving prepared over there
yeah man helicopter lost somebody I'm
helping them out real quick they scour
the globe for unique design focused
products to elevate your style they have
jaw-dropping tech gadgets and gear sleek
iphone cases and accessories sexy home
decor and men's fashion and accessories
sure to get noticed right now our
listeners can get immediate access to
these deals when you sign up a touch of
modern calm that's touch of modern calm
do it today because tomorrow it'll be
different that's how life rolls in the
fast lane both great products you know
what I mean and that's the thing with
these advertisers you know if you're
either texture or touch of modern it's
just another way to support the crap fee
so if you're looking for a little gift
go to touch and modern that's going to
be a great gift for you great you know
this great is our guest this we
excited to have them on been trying to
make it happen for a long time I think
you can enjoy this one we're excited to
have them please welcome for the first
time on the crabbies mr. court McCown
will go the dr e corp again yeah that's
a [ __ ] nice intro like that like that
feels good I Can cuss you write it so
calmly yeah okay help yourself alright
that's good getting shoes on no problem
cause on the golf course with me that's
for damn sure hey Lauren honey this guy
has one bad hole gets upset brings me
down bring oh wait a second let's don't
even go there first of all I'm even
after nine you are so in you [ __ ] the
bed and your temper and then what did I
say and we were playing for money and I
I said no that we what we want your my
team so I I rest of all I one like
hammer home Jesus Christ there it goes
there he goes to the crab he shot a 74
though some on a bad day yeah [ __ ] what
a day towards got skills man well it's
uh it's very exciting to have you here
we're gonna definitely get into this but
before we do why don't you tell people
whatever you want them know about court
McCallum social media your pot okay
social media so yeah so you can go to
Twitter it's at court mccowan cor TMCC
oh WN no a no II know you mm-hmm manly
no way no you know do fun yeah
[ __ ] um that would say that
would be what I'm telling if I play
basketball I'm so that was terrible that
was racist um so then there's that you
got my album which is live from Pearl
Street which you can pick up on all
things comedy is that San Diego yeah I
did it I did it that you can't report
right it's such a great pity record yeah
I mean it's like if you can't kill in la
jolla at the comedy store wit ya just
quit which honestly i've heard the album
and he didn't kill so I mean yeah yeah
yeah I know that's why I will that's why
I'm here that's how I'm here I gotta get
back in man I got to get back in no
check it out because court court tells
it like it is man it's fun elm it's a
fun out it's a funny man then on
Tuesdays every Tuesday I'm live with a
paddle Brian the legendary legendary
announcer from NBA to mca
aight Entertainment Tonight yeah the
voice my voice mail he's the first he's
the first one that will like it he
doesn't have any problem with that he's
like oh yeah the voicemails but what's
is what was his name uh that the bin
found chicks back and all that oh yeah
farm out Albert he's back nobody says
[ __ ] like let's let's slide him in the
radio wins i'm back in no reason for why
should he get why these guys are just
kinky dude he's a freak man that girl's
lie but yet probably like 25 bucks let
you bite my back he didn't have a
problem with who would have a problem
wait so where can they find that uh it's
a thing called WC OB and we're live
every tuesday at ten a.m. pacific time
in los angeles it's me and pat and like
I mean it's great last week we had
Hollywood Henderson Thomas Hollywood
Henderson from the Dallas Cowboys on
that's what she's on mean the guy knows
everybody yeah so it's like and I think
tomorrow or whenever this comes he knows
us to shoulder pads of the plug up the
doorway yeah uh he was great so but it's
fun so it's every tuesday 10am and then
the legendary the who is the real rose
bowl tailgate legend joe Bartnik and i
we we periodically do a podcast called
in sensitivity training which you can
find on all things come as a grain and
yeah yeah perfect we felt we thought I'd
Joe thought of that at a hockey game
because we were trying to think of
something because Joe is not the most
sensitive person and at all yeah and it
was great that's good that's great it's
fun good times had by all I love it man
yeah well I mean I've been wanting to
have you on for a long time because I
would love to there's a lot of things we
want to talk about that we talked about
off mic but I mean I would love to get
in the 80s a little bit the 80s man cuz
I'm oh [ __ ] your mouth man or its old
for all of you amazing huh how old am i
yeah I'm 51 and you do you look look yer
take their he's our Burt Reynolds right
now I like that you want yeah right now
yeah it is i'm going to catch him sing
said with a lot less of a career
I got no no dress no smoking the Bandit
now no smoking abandoned not many oh
yeah oh that guy you know when you look
back on Burt Reynolds career like if you
go back when he was like you know when
he had a really cuz he's got he's had
fake hair since the lights in the
Florida State yeah since the late
sixties yeah no [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] man but he had some bad ass
movies he was a badass sharky's machine
yes yeah that was such a cool movie in
burrows and then he did like cheese dick
like he went to the smokey the bandit
which was still great was easy I know
but I know but I mean like he was like a
serious actor for a while and then he
did what the banner what once there's
about [ __ ] the man I got it yeah yeah
well he loves but I mean he killed it in
what the hell's our code you know okie
dokie nice haha so great that shot when
he's when he used a show him once mark
wahlberg pulls it out and his crate oh
yeah I just cause I imagine was just
like yeah I remember being there for
that because I did the stunt dick for
that so I may be old but it's long no
but you were in a lot of iconic 80s
movies I was in a couple of iconic 80s
movies I did every 80s TV show like it
were you different strokes I didn't do
difference trucks i did family ties I
did shine you really came out Yeah right
they I did the second to the last
episode of family ties i play courtney
cox's new boyfriend and in this in the
show so is that before you did I want I
mean we're gonna do it was that before
can't buy me love her after after after
I had done I done teen wolf with Michael
J Fox teen wolf yeah I did teen wolf
with Michael J Fox and who were you and
Teen Wolf I was on his basketball team
so we were basing all over that slo-mo
seen on every well yeah carry him on my
shoulders off the court but it yes
Slammy wolf paw no no he wasn't the wolf
in the end cuz remember he was so when
it is himself he sucked he was the worst
basketball player everyone the guy in
the wolf costume was the guy's a wolf
costume it wasn't really Michael
no it was this kid from loyola marymount
university I engage basketball player
who was [ __ ] phenomenal but he was
still so short that he had to use a mini
[ __ ] dunk oh he couldn't get I mean was
tiny was like five foot three or
something he was you know little guy
yeah little bitty fella um for that any
point did you at any point did you have
a scene with the wolf oh I'm yeah yeah
when the wolf came it came into the
dance man and I was like oh yeah I was
jamming in my 80s like pastel soon with
the big collar you know dis going Oh
Mallory you I was like 21 then 21 yeah I
was like 21 years old I mean like what's
going through your like how did this all
first of all can I guess we go back to
family tiger he's uh was your famous
favorite thing in the family ties house
I already know a mine I still wanted to
this day what they had a they had a
griddle like the stove was a big stove
but it had like a flat top so like if
you want to make pancakes you don't need
a pan just make them right on the grill
oh really just a little something I
picked up in that little greenhouse
where Emily uh what's her face is
boyfriend's way too much TV out kid I
smoked a lot of weed when I was like 13
so I did you where were you really yeah
I grew up in Oklahoma yeah so you're not
from here I'm not from i moved here in
1984 okay how old were you I was 20 I
came out here for I came out here for I
was gonna come at her for 10 days for a
vacation with who with I was by myself I
came to visit a buddy of mine who lived
out here I knew from college and he was
a stand-in on a TV show that was called
it was it was named it was called dreams
and it was John Stamos and like Jami
Gertz and it was this it was this stupid
was an awful show a nurse during the mtv
like thing we're at the end of every
show they had they did a music video
because they were a band you know they
were all these kids at work in a bar
that had a band and this whole Nephilim
yeah yeah and and the funny thing was is
I can't I partied all night coming out
you know like a party on the plane I was
you know you know is like [ __ ] tons of
blow I was just I was awful we were you
know and he goes you want to be an extra
on the show and I was wrestling did it
just landed and I was like yeah because
I gotta work tomorrow and I was like
what time you go into work because I
gotta leave here at six and we was
working in woodland hills off Shoop
Avenue unless you yeah in July ooh in
July is like 400 [ __ ] degrees out
there and I go sure I'll do it because
it was like it paid like 80 bucks left
out of the blue yeah enough to cover the
plane ticket and the blow this is 1984
yeah so it covered everything and I was
like sure I'll do it and I got out there
and I didn't realize it as an extra you
get treated like dog you know you like a
dog so I'm all hungover I really am so
close to throwing up the whole day and
they kept wanting me to go outside and
I'm like and I didn't have the extra
like equipment like I didn't have the
chair to sit in outside and all its top
professionals but when we went inside we
were in this air conditioned place where
we're shooting the scene and I kept
sneaking back into the air conditioning
and back then I had really long hair you
know and everything and they kept
thinking I was John Stamos from behind
you couldn't tell us about sorry on get
outside would you so the track so the
director of photography came up to me
one point he goes hey do you wanna be
one of work is John's photo double I
need a photo double for John statement
a-standin Anna photo no he didn't they
just had a guy that would alternate
style and form so they said could you be
as we need a photo double for a you know
cuz we shoot all these these music
videos we could use to shoot you from
behind we could let John go blah blah
blah you know I was like sure man I'm
gonna be here for 10 days he goes I need
someone for 10 weeks Oh God rise and I
moved here and that's how I started so
that's hilarious i believe it will first
day and so then well back what I never
went back I never went back I went home
I went home once so I get some clothes
yeah and you know get my car out of
impound and you know I had is at a 75
black Cordova you know they had like mag
wheels and CB radio you know I was
whiter big antennas yeah
Kazmir if you take drive it out no no no
they owned it because it like I had to
get it out of impound it like you know
so I didn't have to pay more to give it
yeah yeah so it was good so then what
you get here and then what's your next
big thing after that Teen Wolf because
the guy the guy that worked the guy that
was the second ad on dreams was like the
guy that wrangles the extras and does
all that stuff he he got this movie and
he goes I need two guys me and my buddy
because I need two guys that can play
basketball that look young that aren't
idiots I don't have because we'd already
worked with this guy for 10 weeks he
loved us yeah so he's like I need I need
somebody that's not going to [ __ ]
everything up and just you know you do
what I tell you to do you just got to
pretend like you know you just be there
because they're all the other actors on
his basketball team were like principles
yeah so we were the only two guys that
were on the court that weren't like part
of the you know we weren't cat did you
have a name no I didn't so who what are
you considered like basketball player 95
or number 33 I took Larry Bird yeah I
took birds number i was a big Larry Bird
yeah it was um so yeah so I did that and
then you know and got Teen Wolf Man and
it was that was fun you know of course
and then can't buy me love came after
that no I worked I worked as a I worked
for this guy who was a it was really
cool like back then being a stand-in was
kind of like knotted asphalt ya know you
did these yet these great jobs because a
stand-in you were Union so it's like it
was there was this screen extra skilled
Union in the sag units egg Union like I
made 140 a day for eight hours that's
pretty good for back now it was great
money and that cludes like your health
insurance all your benefit and all that
stuff and that was 48 hours so you never
worked eight hours she always worked 12
hours he made like 220 buck today yeah
it's crazy and then I worked on this
show called George Burns comedy week and
every week was it was it was like a
different director and a different with
steve martin was the producer in Carl
Gottlieb where the executive producers
and it was like the directors were like
phil alden robinson who did fill the
dreams and sneakers and you know all
those movies steve martin directed one
Carl Gottlieb who wrote jaws he was like
one of the guys but it
like um all the [ __ ] actors were
unbelievable it was it was um telly
savalas um tell Jack Guildford a Don
Knotts Don Rostov and Rickles Rickles
with Rickles Don Johnson I [ __ ] with
articles I do I [ __ ] with Don what we
doing on the show I was a standing so
every week I would stand in for
different guy could be Elliott Gould 1a
or it could be you know Paul Reiser or
it could be it just didn't know you
don't know who it was going to be so
every week was a different show we had
like John Landis directed one you know
you had all these different really cool
directors so but there was one episode I
was doing where it was Don Rickles Don
Knotts Fannie Flagg all these like big
comedic geniuses and John Landis was
directing it and every day how do you at
this point 21 damn and Rickles would
come on the set and he knew I was like
his standing he'd come in and he'd slap
the script on me at my chess ego real
actors are going to work now sit back
kid he was always like just like [ __ ]
just always [ __ ] with me yeah and so
one night like we had all these for some
reason we had all these penthouses on
the set in the prop truck but they had
like National Geographic covers they
were just props yeah and so I started
taking all these pictures i twirl these
pictures out these chicks with her legs
spread you know like I mean the filthy
penthouse pictures you know it's like
dildo shoved and everything and I can I
wrote in like sharpie i wrote to Don's
does this look familiar quickly cinnamon
you know a cider and I stuck a bunch of
min a script you know cuz he kept
popping me at the script you know and
then any into the shot was that day and
then he went home and he comes back the
next day he's like where's the kid
where's the kid that's what he called me
the kid when I was like as I was like oh
[ __ ] what did idea and he goes buddy he
goes i memorize my lines in bed with my
wife and he goes you got me kid you got
me that's amazing bro yeah yeah that guy
was Mary still miss name's Jeff st.
check yeah yeah he's [ __ ] he is [ __ ]
great I've never in my life seen anybody
like we were doing a show one day in a
universal backlot they have the trams
with all the let's just call him some
we're over in the the Far East so
there's a lot of asians on these things
with cameras snapping pictures and so
they always come up in the tramps
combine ago know we're coming up on
George Burns comedy week this week
starting George Burns and you know blah
blah saying all these names and
everyone's outside we're eating outside
you know craft services all out out
there and [ __ ] Rickles waits till the
last minute and we had his ad well he
was warned who was black I mean warm was
black black you know but he was the
sweetest guy in the world but he wore
like button down oxford shirts with like
pressed jeans and white Reeboks and you
know he was just a nicest guy in the
world and he waited till the tram starts
coming up and he went he stacked a tray
full of fried chicken and watermelon and
wrinkles Rickles did and he waited till
the Tran comes under the ladies and
gentlemen starring Don Rickles and
Fannie Flagg in anything and he in
wrinkles walks right everything and he
goes he lunch mr. Warren here's your
lunch and he just saw this thing and
everyone's just snapping pictures and I
laughs I'm all everybody I mean war left
is that I'm sure he did it was good
stuff I mean Rickles like I remember
seeing him on Leno and it was Denzel
Washington and was the first guest and
then it was Rickles and Rickles sit next
to have you seen that it's humble brag
knows just just keeps turning over and
grabbed by the shoulders like you know
your people it'll say sup and Denzel
turns the audience like can you believe
this guy's say this right now but he's
like laughing he's like this guy's you
know he's amazing did you see home in
vegas in two thousand and he just it was
picked out one black dude in one asian
lady and he just hammered him throughout
the entire hour and then at the end of
the night he acts like he the casino
pays for like a watch for her and some
other really nice [ __ ] for him but he
act like it's him you know he's like a
type of a big good sports I'm gonna go
get you she's good she's like oh my god
i watch he's like you're welcome yeah
well he's [ __ ] great did you ever see
his like tribute they did they did this
big tribute in spike right on spy I have
had you gotta see it because he like he
says something goes I'm so glad you're
here like to the plate goes he goes
because my room is unlocked you know
does he's rather like that is he's the
last of the right path he can do it man
you can do it cuz he doesn't mean it and
he doesn't mean it harm he means it and
it's funny it's funny it's funny [ __ ] so
then tell us uh how you came about can't
buy me love because J we were talking
like that is that's an that's just an
iconic film I mean I love that I we had
a snapper tractor we had the same track
it ready really yeah well he had to
fight him on man it's funny that's and
everything I went in and I read for I
remember going in and auditioning for
the Ronald character for the Patrick
Dempsey everybody i think everybody went
in red for the Patrick Dempsey part and
then they can't then they call me back
in and they said I went in for this
producer session and they called me in
to play like this character quit which
wasn't a very big role in the for in
originally it was a very very small part
I had like three scenes and and I went
in and I auditioned and this director
was a great director this guy Steve rash
who directed like Buddy Holly story I
mean he directed some pretty big big
things at the time and it was just one
of those things where you went in and I
just I didn't know what I was doing I
was still like I was like 23 or some 22
23 and I'm auditioning I'm supposed to
grab this little kid and I'm supposed to
like intimidate him and I don't know
what you're like a bully yeah I was a
bully and I you know I was and I was in
acting classes you know at the time and
it was like I was studying method acting
you know so i thought i was really a
knew what I was doing I had no [ __ ]
clue and I end up like going in and I
just grabbed this guy and I just started
[ __ ] the directory and I didn't
realize until afterwards or just a
director so I grabbed the director in
the directory and they [ __ ] loved it
yeah and and so yeah so I booked that
thing and then I remember flying to
tucson and the writer was this guy
Michael swirl it was a really cool guy
and we're right we're on the plane to
Tucson he goes dude we loved you in the
foot we loved you in the audition we
beefed it up a bit loved you hammer time
yeah love you I
family guy that was much later but um
but yeah so it ended up being and it was
a small movie it was a movie called boy
rents girl and that was the original
title original title and it was made by
this little studio called Apollo Studios
which was a tiny little company this guy
Jerry Henshaw I'll never forget this it
was this guy who made like really shitty
movies I mean like really shitty movies
that don't are still you can't find
anywhere they're that bad and I me and
we made this movie and we got done with
the movie and we had a party one night
and that durand the guy that was the one
of the producers of it brought everybody
in and he goes I want to make an
announcement you know at this big party
and it's like you know this is the first
movie the touchstone which is owned by
disney is the first movie they ever
bought that they didn't make so they
bought this movie they pumped like
another million and a half into it and
we did reshoots we did some other stuff
and then they put it out in 1800
theaters and over the number one movie
wow that's like of that you know
whatever cuz back today's almost indie
style it's it's weirdest yeah 1800 yeah
back then yes it's huge i was huge back
by 1800 1800 s know what am I thinking
yet is a friend to theatre on everywhere
I got a friend whose movie just got
bought and they got released on 75
screens and I'm like dude that's
unbelievable yeah we were released in
hundred eighteen hundred screens we were
then / 50 states do the math man I can't
I can't do that man that's like 30 s
that's like iron 1858 there you know
like six beer till tomorrow yeah now I'm
but it was like amazing and we did this
thing and it became this big [ __ ] hit
it was great besides us mega hit it wit
we still got a residual check do you
know you don't like a horsey that's
insane and everything is if you're
comfortable at saying what's the average
of that residual check and now well the
biggest cuz what what's the how many
years now at this point how many yes it
30 years you still get check oh and
they're like and it's like you know you
open it up one day and i'll be like five
fifty or something yeah that's great
i'll never forget the first time I
opened it up I nearly [ __ ] my pain
I nearly [ __ ] this is your first
residual beyond what you were paid you
what what were you paid to do this like
10 maybe 10 grand yeah first residual
check was twenty-six thousand holy [ __ ]
you got paid ten and yeah because they
because they base it on how much the
movie made versus like I'm sure [ __ ]
patrick dempsey got a 2.6 million yeah I
got 26,000 he got like yeah whatever
your points I praise and then it just
it's been continuing gravity it's gone
way after that yet um yeah i mean i
still get i get checked against on for
Teen Wolf no you know that you said they
went bankrupt well they cut my [ __ ] they
cut my lines what wouldn't know every
team re-release or so know when they did
Teen Wolf I had like two lines all I see
and so when you have lines you always
get residuals you always get something
but in the when they did the final cut
they I had like two lines were like
there was one in a bowling alley where I
had a line and there was another line on
the basketball court and they cut both
those things so it's just like you know
and it didn't matter it wasn't like you
know so what was it like then at that
point because that movie blew up and
clearly just on your flight out here
you're a little bit of a maniac like wow
I went on in Hollywood in LA you
involved yeah yeah away LA in like let's
say mediate yeah who dat r who was like
who's crushing at that point um guns and
roses all yet oh yeah do I saw guns and
roses like everyone was like on the guns
and roses at Coachella I'm like [ __ ]
that man yeah I saw guns and roses open
for the stones with living it went
living color then then guns and roses
and then the rolling stones oh my and it
was [ __ ] awesome at the Coliseum that
was a great show yeah yeah I bet you
know but I mean Guns and Roses was like
I mean they were big um I'm trying to
think man there was so like you too was
like this [ __ ] but I mean like in as far
as I didn't like here on the surround
with like other like yeah like on the
strip and stuff like that or like weird
is like the strip wasn't like where
everything was like like now you go up
and down the strip and there's like you
know there's a there's a clubs you know
Bootsy bellows or there's you know and I
don't even know really I'm just saying
the names they're out there but most of
the club's back then were downtown so
there was a club called vertigo which
was the first club that ever had a
velvet rope in LA that you know they
came from New York and they put a velvet
rope up which made him you know you
couldn't go in yeah you know but it was
like you could go in you just had a lot
of blow if you wanted to go in but
anyway you're getting access to
everything because every this movie just
took off I got I got I became buddies
with a bunch of guys that grew up here
you know that grew up in one of the guys
was likened it was like a in the
production company that produced our
movie and we became buddies so it was
like and then he was well connected you
know with everybody and I mean he's kind
of like it was just kind of like not the
not the whatever they called the the
brat pack because that was kind of like
kind of old like that was kind of old
hat that wasn't really that wasn't that
cool of a group to be honest with you
you know but there was like this great
like crowd that hung out there was a bar
called flaming Colossus which was down
on a thin Bonnie brea in downtown and it
was this [ __ ] cool ass club and there
was like I mean I'll tell you how cool
was they had a little jazz room there's
a little jazz room off to the side and
Bono and edge would go in there and jam
with these guys when they were doing
rattle and hum look on the back around
damn and they think that one of their in
their liner notes they thanked flaming
Colossus because they would go in there
and jam with these jazz and blues guys
so you'd be in the club you know just
snortin your brains out having a great
time drinking your ass off and then you
just kind of cruise down in this little
room and there would be bono and edge
you'd be sitting there jamming with
these guys on blues it was [ __ ] it
was awesome in its it was a lot
different i mean you know i mean i I
don't I mean the inner I hate to say the
Internet's [ __ ] everything I mean
trust me i'm behind you i think the
internet is [ __ ] everything I agree
until just recently i'll say this
quickly because never have I seen
anything like the outpouring of love and
positivity for prints oh yeah it's
amazing I haven't seen one person
it on Prince know and um and and I i
just find it like so I I completely
agree with you but there are just these
moments where I've seen Springsteen
opened his uh tour or his night with
purple rain fish did 1999 I mean it's
those are things we used to just hear
about but now you can see that and I was
like what everyone loves prints yeah
I'll tell you right now if if there
wasn't the internet what you would have
seen instead of seeing all the she's in
it you would have seen all these big
vigils held in each century which would
have happened because and actually would
have communicated with each other
instead of putting on their facebook
page their picture picture they found on
[ __ ] google images of prints going oh
I love Tim I all entire life thank you
how many likes can I get from this you
piece of [ __ ] I mean I know but I'm I
don't know that's my bit of first- the
guard about price no but it was uh yeah
I know I mean there was just this like
you could go in you could go places but
he kind of had to hear about it yeah so
wasn't like you knows would you would
you say la was smaller than not
size-wise but like now there's like I
mean just obviously there's more people
and it was all I mean when I live when I
first moved here in 84 there was one
area code yeah two one three two and
three is for LA and the valley Wow like
they finally split them when I moved
here like 84 85 they made an 818 area
code yeah and now there's what like
seven arrow and back then there was
there plus two cell phones I've TV
stations back then right no no there was
cable dude yeah i know but like how many
people were pretty good content I mean
MTV did play music video right but yeah
they're 457 HBO but like who else is
making tea moment TBS yet you had all
yet all the kill okay they were all then
yeah i mean i don't know we didn't have
cable so I for me was 4 or 5 7 25 and 38
and 56 do you have those little [ __ ]
rabbit ears on there no foil around yeah
yeah time to hear um but then like you
know if you were in a movie back then
like independent film wasn't what it is
or became especially with the digital
era or you could just go make a movie so
like when you're getting in movies back
then you were like all it was a
different it was a different time I
Touchstone Pictures presents
yeah exactly and the thing was too is
like it when you shoot across the bottom
yeah I love that man do you mean I just
was watching old 80's movie promos the
other day and just checking them out
because they're so just bang bang
they're [ __ ] his era pay off this
summer so bad they're so bad but I was
just saying this year the day like I
didn't get the cool catch phrase though
like like in the 80s like there was
always like wax on wax off ur that kid
got soda metabolically so it is [ __ ] me
you know just want like you realize how
much money that guy makes online yeah
through one of those out yeah like just
a t-shirt alone like sweep the leg that
I could make a million dollars I can't
put Quint on his in let the fun begin
even on the front of a t-shirt yeah I
have to put that on a [ __ ] banner
behind an airplane got to sell a car
wreck I ought to put a car wrap I can't
that again you know many times that guys
like just like getting coffee the guys
like I how much I'd like sweep the leg
man like just here and sweep the leg
every day [ __ ] oh yeah for free coffee
they can say Quentin is in all [ __ ]
day long man that's the line i had a lot
of one like Quentin is in let the fun
begin that's when i get a lot and but I
be you know honest with you man people
ask me I'll [ __ ] do it for Matt
Harvey I don't want to [ __ ] are you
kidding i always wonder if people would
get just beast like Jay just said sick
of here in that sleep delay know if
you're sick of hearing that you're a
dick you know because it's like you did
this thing people like it why why
wouldn't he likes why wouldn't you I
mean I'm embrace flattered when people
say that when people go I really love
that movie if I'm happy it's like I feel
good about that do people ever mess your
movie up know who you are me oh I love
gin something like I stopped I didn't
have like a movie I don't get that uh
not know they get sixteen Candles men
yes like that like get the movies like
that no problem I'm just like yeah let's
go get right [ __ ] like that did it
yeah you like that should take your
clothes off tell me about what you just
telling us a little bit about the
roxbury oh man yeah what kind of [ __ ]
like it no way well roxbury let's see
Roxbury opened it had
Miyagi's was right yeah me August but
before that it was actually place called
it was a place called imperial gardens
in the original place was imperial
gardens before was before it was Roxbury
imperial gardens and you used to be
above the club upstairs what we call the
arsenio hall lounge which is this big
like VIP area upstairs which overlooked
the Sunset Strip they used to do a thing
called the boss club on Tuesday nights
and it was all Springsteen music all
night every tuesday night it was very
cool quite as cool that was fun um
roxbury [ __ ] a min that place was I
was here I remember I was here for
college in the Roxbury I was here when
the Roxbury was still there and across
the street was Carlos Charley Crowson
generally girls used to dance on the
rooftop on whatever Wednesday night or
whatever and peep at became Dublin's
yeah okay Dublin and people started
hitting you know bumper to bumper good
looking up at these [ __ ] hot chicks
dancing on the roof three or four of
them out there in the city made him stop
doing it yeah I remember that's when I
got here for college but and then I came
back later but I remember roxburghshire
used to say that Arsenio was in there
all the time i used to call that we used
to call the VIP area there was a VIP
area upstairs and we called it the
arsenio hall lounge because every
because this when he was doing his show
yeah and he would always roll in there
with the [ __ ] and it was like they're
not with but I mean there were just tons
of chicks there and that place was that
place was [ __ ] insane I bet it was
insane and I was out of control then I
mean that was that was like bad that was
a bad time drinking what are you doing
drinking just you name it and your if I
could smoke it snort its drink it or I
didn't inject it as much but but
anything you could do you did release 25
now how I'm like I'm 20 yeah no I'm all
during that I'm like 27 28 because it
was like that was really kicking in like
nineteen ninety 90 you know somewhere in
there 90 91 to 90 that's when I got here
91 yeah and I mean they had like you go
in and downstairs was like the Blues Bar
they had a blues bar down standing this
guy Roy something came in burrows last
name he always play
blues in there so we go in there we knew
the guys we know a guy that owned it you
know we'd roll in and we put a bottle of
Yukon jack on ice and then there was a
back door in the downstairs so you could
go through the back door in the
downstairs and that's where you go and
you you know you clear your head but
there was a secret tunnel there there
was a tunnel that was down there that
sealed up that used to be a tunnel where
they would go to the garden of Allah
which is the guard where that was on the
corner of Crescent Heights where there's
mcdonalds and the bank and all that used
to be this big huge oh yeah nothing used
to be a apartment complex oh is that
what it was because I know now it's like
one of those mega like 10 [ __ ] uh you
know blare music [ __ ] dance places no
no no credit dollars across the song
actually where McDonald yeah weird yeah
whole era shop and walk corner from that
corner that corner used to be this big
apartment complex called garden of Allah
and that's where like all the old movie
stars lived and everything so they
actually had tunnels it would go down
underneath sunset that would go up to
guard of Allah like The Comedy Store if
you look when you first walk in the back
door that's a tunnel that goes down from
Siros when it was zero days there were
tunnels that went down underneath sunset
that they would get people out but we go
down there shoot guns so oh yeah yeah
I'll [ __ ] up shoot guns down who had
the guns I'm not gonna say who had the
guns but let's just say was proprietors
and then they just had we would just be
[ __ ] around get all [ __ ] up and you
know someone go yeah you know [ __ ] it
now you know yeah just for shits and
giggles you know but you were downstairs
you couldn't hear anything yeah as far
as i know i mean you know cuz you know
Pete johansson I don't know if I nopee i
did like a tour with Pete up in like a
Tribble run like Pacific Northwest and
Pete used to bartend there when he first
moved to LA he got like a development
deal he was bartending at the roxbury
and jay davis was barbacking for him oh
no [ __ ] yeah Jay used to bar back there
and he told me the craziest things he's
ever seen his life were at the roxbury
he said like just like shannen doherty
doing blow off the bar Tom Cruise sit in
the corner by himself
that he saw a guy shoot a machine gun on
sunset yeah like I said it was just
insanity I mean you beat you'd be
sitting at a table and you know everyone
be hand in the bindle around you know
blow and you know Terence Trent d'Arby
would sit down next yeah yeah Terence
Trent d'Arby soon as you how you doing
man yeah yeah yeah here you go you know
haha hey you know adjust Evers just soak
this crazy like place cuz there was like
all these booths on the window you know
and so it was like all these booths so
you would just if you were in a booth
you know who knew who came and sat down
with you and it was he's crazy like it's
just as crazy time and it was like super
and it was a coke was like really kind
of like it was over there was too much
of it around and it was everybody was
doing it so wasn't like you know I mean
I don't know how much of it there is now
around I'm sure it's around you know but
I mean now it's a little more you know
like you're out publicly you know what
coke yeah that shit's everywhere I know
what's ever say it's not like I don't a
table yeah but it's not like you go to
somebody's house and there's like a
butter dish on the coffee table though
it's got a big pile on it and everyone
just kind of walks by D was that what
does well yeah it was like that all
everywhere I mean just go places and it
was like I mean if you you know the
different I me not everywhere you go but
you know if you went to somebody's house
for a late-night party at 2am you know
cuz that's what you would usually happen
or you shut the bar down you know they
closed the doors and then then the party
would start you know busy to get
everybody else out and you keep about 20
people in and you just you know stay
there till seven in the morning I mean
shooting guns downstairs in the rock
spray sounds like a cocaine thing that
doesn't definitely suck at that without
like Jane driven I was going say that's
just alcohol by it so no not at all
there's nothing it's gotta smoke a cave
is like who's gotta go yeah i remember i
was i mean i i've never seen so many
like I lived in New York for a couple
years in like 91 293 and we sit on this
place called III merrily which was on
West Broadway down Soho and there was
this crazy [ __ ] guy am Persian guy
who was like ran etree merrily and they
had all these like bottles on the wall
when we go in there we do these shots of
espresso vodka shots with him and just
do major rails with this guy and he
would just pull out a gun just our shoot
the [ __ ] I was like what is it with tons
of cocaine know what it is man it's like
all these like crazy dude you have like
[ __ ] tons of coke always have a gun and
I always and I never had a gun I ain't
gonna do scare the [ __ ] out all me too
I'm Oklahoma's ooh yeah I don't like
guns man but yeah there's like something
about that I don't know what it was they
get I mean how else do you get that
release I snap a gun off I guess just
cooking something come on take care
yourself oh man I don't know but yeah
that was a the 80s was full of coke and
[ __ ] where they're crazy like after
parties is that like we are finding
yourself like like crazy parties oh yeah
I mean you go you go to parties and it'd
be like you know you'd be sitting there
you know I know I remember I was at a
party in the hills one time and they you
know they were smoking like I mean
really good weed back because now you
guys get medical weed it's everywhere
but like the really good [ __ ] you know
that you smell now that just smells like
a you know puppy farted okay so sweet
you know and I remember I sent at a
party in the hills one time and these
guys were smoking a joint and they put
the joint down and they left and it was
like it wasn't a small joint it's like a
fat like you know like a huge joint and
I was like I looked around and there
they [ __ ] left and so I just picked
the joint up put it my sand back it's
like he can't leave that there was Billy
Idol in his crew okay where's on my way
and I couldn't go it's it i I'm sorry I
took it as I don't know where it is that
somebody took off [ __ ] wait you know
and I was like sorry to Billy Idol here
sorry I thing might have herpes on a dud
I got [ __ ] everything back then yeah
that's our Billy Idol here that's okay
how are we free of there that's what
everyone was just [ __ ] too right
everyone was [ __ ] it was good yeah it
was good I mean I'll be honest though I
think I had more fun I think I'm more
actually when I got sober in 2001
I think he got better because now I
could like you know I I mean was a lot
of it is like a total blur for you um a
lot of it yeah I mean a lot there's a
lot yeah in and and also it's like it
was before it was before everybody had a
cell phone before texting so it's like
you know you get home at 130 and you
start calling up you know your ladies
you go into your address book you're
opening up your [ __ ] what do they
call like a little black book not that
black book remember the be a runner day
runner up your [ __ ] day runner you're
going to be in your [ __ ] college
chicks in your day runner and and it's
like and it's one thirty in the morning
and you know and it's like your call you
know you're you're waking them up and
you're like yeah what's uh you know hey
okay Marty you want a party and they're
like it's like who what are you [ __ ]
insane it's one thirty in the morning
like I'm gonna get up get dressed and
come over to your house when you're like
coked out of your head but you always
found someone who would so you know if
every you know so there's always like
it's kind of gross but that's kind of
fun what was the tipping point what made
you be like I gotta get sober it was
just so much man I mean I was older it
was like it did enough since what I mean
was it like so there was like a big
thing you just like oh you know what I
just need to quit this stuff or was it
like your life was going down my life
was going it was it was getting up it
was bad it was bad i mean i remember i
had a birthday party i was i turned 37
and i had a birthday party my buddy let
me borrow his house up in the Hollywood
borrow house huge mistake a huge mistake
he was there but it was like but it was
cool and I had like 300 of my closest
friends show up oh my god because that's
what it was like you know you had a
party it's like you know your friends
call you know there it was like a you
know court was having a party there was
you know they knew what was going on
yeah [ __ ] and and I and I remember
sitting in the middle aiming for the
kind of one thing I remember about it i
had done like a couple it's ecstasy
probably about half of a ounce of blow
God knows how much blow I'd done that
night I drank at least a fifth of vodka
and I'm sitting in the middle of the
living room floor just like grinding my
teeth and you know and it's like that's
not fun yeah you know and I ended up
going home with someone I swore I
wasn't gonna go home with molly ringwald
no no I wish what a pain while yeah yeah
I would and I would have been high but I
would have got it yeah yeah and so that
was it you that was kind of right off
right around that time no I I kinda was
like done I think I you know in this is
like we're like everyone's like oh you
quit it's like I didn't quit i retired I
mean I'm like I'm like Barry Sanders of
cocaine you know I quit on top we went
out on time for the real damage for the
[ __ ] really concussion problems Kurt
I had one heart attack though that was
wait what yeah I had a heart attack on
the [ __ ] in Las Vegas how old were
you I was 36 oh my gosh then you kept
doing cocaine after that that same night
yeah oh [ __ ] you got out of the hospital
went and did my go to the hospital got
wait hold on so so here's what happens
so I was with a friend and I can't say
because your own guy in a robbery or
yeah and I was as which I want to get
back to buy my god and we had a we'd
been we've been up for like two days
three days we go to Vegas a ton no this
was this was just I happen to be in
Vegas a friend of mine it got shot at a
Halloween party this guy i did this
black is black dude he got he got killed
shot the back shot dead shot dead by
[ __ ] police officer at a Halloween
party holy and it was this big deal he
was dressed as I thought it would be
fine not really um but anyway so I was
like kind of this like kind of sad thing
and I went to vatan went to Vegas for
this thing I was supposed to be doing I
was working this job which I hated you
know and so I was there and so I just
took like an ounce of coke with this
body mine and we've got this suite at
the hard rock and we just dumped this
whole out to blow out on the on the
table and that's like the loneliest idea
enemy right yeah and we ended up and we
ended up staying up for like three days
you know sleep drinking minimal food at
best and I was in the bathroom trying to
take a [ __ ] I don't know why I was
trying to get [ __ ] I hadn't eaten
anything in three [ __ ] days yeah and
I was just so constipated from all the
coke and I was sitting there and all of
a sudden I just had a disc lost I
couldn't breathe I had I lost all the
feeling in the left side of my body
shortness
sweating profusely I mean is everything
I could do just to breathe I couldn't
call security because we had all these
drugs there my buddy was in the other in
the other bedroom of the suite with a
hooker she was a hooker yeah hang on
it's fast and it was and I literally
crawled out of the bathroom and I
remember I just remember thinking to
myself I'm not famous enough to die on
the [ __ ] you know nobody knows who I
lu a hello you know this man and I
crawled out of that crawled out of the
[ __ ] bed room or the bathroom crawled
in the bed room laid on the bed for
probably two hours what probably like
two two and a half hours I don't think
it was like a one of like a major like
stroke heart attack but I mean it was
all like I looked it up after like all
the stuff like it was every symptom type
of a [ __ ] heart attack you could have
I mean everything everything down to the
[ __ ] the how it started the tingling
then the chest pains and the numbers in
the left arm and the whole left side of
my body window I mean I was crawling
with buck naked hardware about my ankles
if you buddy Kimberly are you shot and
then the funny thing was is like and
then yeah go two and a half hours later
I felt okay like I was sitting there I
was like you know okay not only okay
okay enough to do more coke I did I did
two lines jumped in the shower we went
out that night you know and that was
partly that wasn't a sign I know good
yeah that was in October and I didn't
get sober till the next September holy
[ __ ] I had a lot left in me I was trying
to get a ring man I was trying to get
away I had one more season
and I need to get a ring so you uh you
mentioned Rod Stewart earlier was that
the you know there was like I'm either
there was this place called Helena's
that was down on off Beverly in like
temple or something it was this club man
years ago and it was like this was in
the 80 still so this was like I mean it
was like I mean cocaine was not
addictive yet yeah it was so yeah and
and I remember you'd walk in a bathroom
and Elena's there be like Rod Stewart
and you know Rob Lowe and you know
everyone would just be in the bathroom
just like I mean it's everyone was just
just just it was everywhere yeah it was
everywhere everybody did it back then
nobody will deny they did nobody can
deny that there wasn't this just massive
amount of it around yeah and you know
the thing was is it was just expensive
you know it was is so expensive back
then that's why I think that's why it
was kind of in that you know more feet
Liberty more people would have done it I
mean there wasn't crack back then right
you know cracked and come around till
like you know like 89 you know I think
80 good year for correct yeah 18 I was
like idea from crap yeah I never said
well yeah once did you really want with
a couple of hookers in in in in seattle
in seattle well I thought you'd say
Vegas know and see how he doing up there
I was up there I was I was working for
my I was like I just come back I just
come back from New York and I was trying
to know what to do I was trying to get
back into acting because I taken a break
and and I was trying to figure out so my
buddy hired me to work for this company
he ran and I was like the sales manager
of this company and I was doing a
presentation for home depot in Seattle
and I went up and I was like I'm just
you know I'm just gonna take a bindle
one bindle with me you know and I'm not
gonna do any of it of course I'm
snorting all the way up there on the
plane oh my god and then I got a hotel
room at the airport and you know one
thing led to another and i ran a coke
and the hookers head crack and so I
smoked some crack with the hookers and
was a great I closed the deal with home
depot
tell you commit every bus where every
person has come on here I feel like that
said they've smoked crack said it's
absolutely like I cast I couldn't tell
you I was so coked out when I did it oh
it's like I couldn't even tell you like
I didn't hear one a few times but I was
so coked out I couldn't tell you what it
was like I'm gonna get to enjoy my god
yeah I think it's a shame let me ask you
this hold on you you're the best golfer
I know that I played off with look we
playing golf all through all this um
yeah viaB not as much I wasn't it wasn't
you know you weren't at that I mean like
I've gone to the driving range before
and he just happens to be there and the
golf pros just stand there with court
and they watch us what he's not paying
for a lesson they just know when they
look at the swing the leg at yeah that's
good that's good what's going on here
well it's like I remember I remember I
was like I remember there was one time
I'll tell you one funny story i was
playing in the club championship I was
remember this men's club this appalling
a men's club over there at encino Balboa
and I had a four-shot lead going into
the last day it was a three-day
tournament and I the night before like I
had been really good like I lay all
right I'm not party man this is the this
the club championship I had a four-shot
lead going to the last day well the
Saturday now you know it's on sunday so
saturday night of course in my buddy's
like what you have a couple drinks man
i'm gonna do not you know so you know
cut to seven in the morning i'm doing a
line before i go to the MS not mostly
doing a big fat gagger before i hit hit
the thing and we are the last group to
go off and i like and for some reason i
was like fine you know I started out as
fine then we slowed up you know we had
to wait and I was in a golf cart and I
passed out and I just I fell asleep and
I could in it and I just I how many
holes in four holes in it on and I was
like oh and I just I they couldn't get
you up you couldn't do it anymore below
yeah so I mean if i had a like a little
thing with you yep I could have kept
going but and they got this qualify for
being awesome no I know I ended up like
this involve I know they won't make
Emily out there like dude you're falling
behind you know you gotta catch it and
that you know you know like you wake up
all you know like all the way you are I
don't know where you are you don't know
what's going
on and it's like you know I mean you
can't play golf like no but I'm so do
you leave no I finished like I like I
lost by like eight strokes mass or what
an [ __ ] I had that big so much too
man i can't believe that but i've been
playing golf since i was a kid yeah I
understand it's still like when you're
that committed to party and you know I
mean some things go by the but you
mentioned you caddy Don uh pga champion
store yeah i met i met this guy um yes /
Parnevik who's like a swedish golfer yes
will my favorite golfer grown I mean
outside like Obama Nicholas cuz you know
what yes Burt would do he where is brim
up like this when I was a kid he were
like flashy pants in Swedish super thin
he was always the fresh he was the
Rickie Fowler are well for Ricky p.m.
here's a guy invented styling golf yeah
hundred percent and he pulled her
[ __ ] wishes he is yes proponent not
even close yeah and but yes / and I met
I played in I played in this in you know
I was in Hawaii I went to Y with john
corbett jon was one of my best friends
jon was who's on sex drugs and rock and
roll now he was okay My Big Fat Greek
Wedding he was on Sex in the City at the
time and so we known each other since
you know way before he ever did northern
exposure in this show so but he was
going to Hawaii Mercedes invited him to
go to the big Mercedes championship you
know which is the first term of the year
and this was before a lot of celebrities
play golf so it was like you know it's
kind of news 2001 not that many people
you know new you know so he gets invited
because i want to bring my buddy and so
we stayed at like the ritz-carlton you
know it was [ __ ] unbelievable sure
and the whole thing was that he was
supposed to play in this golf tournament
we get there and I took him out he'd
never played golf and I didn't realize
that and I was like well dude you got it
you're gonna have to play in this pro-am
with like people that paid money till I
got Lena pro-am so there'll be a pro
celebrity and the people who pay huge
money huge money like five thousand
dollars apiece you know for a day of
golf it's all goes charity it all goes
to charity so this and this one is air
update the Mercedes flies in all their
top dealers so they have a huge I mean
you you clear staying for
nights at the ritz-carlton it's the
ritz-carlton yeah the ritz-carlton in uh
in [ __ ] Maui at kapalua it's [ __ ]
tent TJ event yeah they fly you
first-class they give us a Mercedes when
we get there to drive around the island
and so we get out and we go out to hit
golf balls i took a whole bucket of golf
balls out you know took on the drone the
golf course we after nine holes he
didn't have a single ball at he goes I
can't play I can't play so he went to
the lady and Mercedes he's lucky as I
can't do this she's like John I mean you
know we flew out here you know she's
kind of in a way trying to in he goes
I'll tell you what I'll caddy for my
buddy court he can play in the event and
there he's like I'll carry his club's
I'll be there all my face the whole nine
yards they're like okay that's cool but
we ended up getting paired with parnevik
and we won the pro-am we like we shan't
yeah it was great we had a blast you in
part of it yeah it's a [ __ ] blast and
and we because he kept walking through
people's lines yeah yeah but we became
like really good friends like you know
cut 25 years later I'm toastmaster his
40th birthday party yeah I mean we just
became really close and so in 2013 he
was on the PGA Tour so on the PGA Tour
and he had had medical exemption so he
was only going to play like 12 events
and he called me up and he goes he will
you caddy for me at the LA open at the
Riviera and I was like [ __ ] no I don't
carry people's bags man [ __ ] off you
know and he goes it'll be fun we'll have
a blast and so I ended up doing it and
he made the cut made some money we had
some fun I was terrible I was awful
really worse caddy ever why did you
because you want I didn't know what I
was doing I mean I know what caddy was
you know and I mean I'd seen it but like
I mean the professional it's really it
there's like rules I mean there's like
they're good like an etiquette there's
like a real etiquette like you don't
hand a guy club like I'd pull up I'd
pull up to the teen like have his drive
around handed to me like now I'll get my
driver you know but I mean those guys
will go out like the night before and go
to each green and just drop balls and
you'd be able to tell him like look at
this is gonna break this way this breaks
from here you would i jacked but I did
know like a new Riviera really well so I
knew where nothing broke so I knew what
to tell him what to do on the greens and
everything like that so it was it was
fun and then a couple weeks later I was
doing a club is doing the improv in
Dallas Addison improv you know like
Saturday night he called me goes hey i'm
playing tampa next week he goes when you
come caddy for me in tampa you know said
of going home and I was like uh you know
and he goes listen afterwards we'll
drive back to West Palm you know where
he lives and he goes and you can see the
wife and I know his family I love his
kids and everything and he goes you come
back and see the family hang out for a
few days and then you fly home after
that you guys will have a blast I was
like [ __ ] sounds great so I did that and
as we're driving home from Tampa he made
the cut made some money and he's like
what are you just County for me this
year you know be you know I don't kiss
is hard to get a caddy a professional
guy that if you're only doing this week
and you're not doing that week yeah i'm
not doing you know and i'm sure like
when you're getting a little bit older
like he was he's just like it's all
about just having fun and being with
someone you know and you get along with
because I mean how many guys get along
super old okay you always know you hear
about filling bones Phil Mickelson his
caddy you mean or I mean we had some
great times like we did the Greenbrier
we did Greenbrier tournament which is
here been up there it's one of the most
beautiful places in the world this green
buyer in West Virginia and we played
like he had just been in Sweden for six
weeks so he shows up there's rust on his
golf clubs I'm like dude you haven't uh
complete golf and he's like no it's been
a good vacation he's a little got a
little wine belly on him you know yeah
and I was like holy [ __ ] this is gonna
be a short week we're going to miss this
[ __ ] cut and everything and then
we're staying at the green or at the
Greenbrier this beautiful resort and we
played with jordan Spieth the horse
students and we played this in trauma
dudeman ya know this kid was like we we
were we were like jordan Spieth were
like first two days were like we don't
give it the big deal is you know and
then we realize up for two days he was
like seven under par that he's just
there's nothing flashy he's just [ __ ]
great he doesn't miss anything so anyway
so I'm he missed the cut and he's like
to [ __ ] this I'm going home I go the
[ __ ] you are I didn't fly all the way to
West Virginia to [ __ ] him fly home on
[ __ ] Saturday you're gonna we're
going to get really drunk and you're
going to [ __ ] practice and then we're
going to [ __ ] in Illinois
on Sunday and you're going to [ __ ]
play next week because I didn't come
here for one week you to [ __ ] off and
he's like oh [ __ ] so I took him and made
him drink single malt all night long and
you weren't drinking no but he he was in
a black he didn't remember going home
what woke up the next day it's July it's
[ __ ] like 94 in a hundred ten percent
humidity and he's out there pants you
know cuz you get on the range and he's
just shan't wear shorts yeah he's just
sweating his ass off we practiced all
day and we went through you know he made
it you went the next week but but I I
did that I I [ __ ] had a plan can you
tell us what you said to him remember
you telling me in the course of the day
what you like you got in his face a
little bit a long hike yeah we were red
well the Champions Tour is a little
different champions tour was like we I
agreed like when we I was at his house
one time and I was like so who you gonna
lose gonna caddy for in the Champions
journey cuz I'm I so I want a caddy I
want to do the Champions Tour I want to
be your full-time caddy and he's like
sure and this is like I mean these guys
are [ __ ] good anybody who there's a
bet but also when you turn 50 you can go
on the Champions Tour and usually the
number one guy on tour outside of
bernhard langer who's like 75 and still
doing well in the PGA Tour it's the guys
who just turned 50 that like crush it
because they have like ten you know I
mean no it's not it's not like that's
not like that it's like these guys that
you everybody has these crazy weeks like
most guys come on the tour and they
think because they're 15 they're still
young and they can crush it that they're
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of everybody
what they don't realize is these guys
are so good they're so precise they can
hit it within five feet or ten feet and
they make every putt yeah so um but what
we kind of like we had kind of an
auspicious start for the first like six
seven weeks like we did well in a couple
tournaments but he's I mean golfers are
psychos I mean all golfers are a little
psychotic you know like the cuddling
court when we golf the other day lovers
well seen your temper and but they
always like they always want to blame
the caddy it's always what they do they
always want to blame you and it's like
and it is what it is but it's just and
you got to let him do it you just gotta
let them blow off steam you know that's
what you do you just let them
all steam but we were playing when you
say blow off steam though are they
openly embarrassing you in front all
these people or no no no they're just
and they don't it's it's very kind of
quietly and it's just kind of you and
it's like really it's like I should have
hit this and it's like no you shouldn't
[ __ ] hook that and that Club would
have been fine yeah but you [ __ ]
hooked it and now we're 10 yards left
were dead and that's your fault but of
course i will just go yeah yeah that's
probably would have been a better idea
you just could you keep their psyche I
don't even going yeah but we were
playing he fired me it was my best
friend he fired me on a Saturday on a
Saturday on a Saturday not know I was
still you know he said that the next
weekend I was going to use somebody else
and so you know on sunday he shot the
two worse rounds I've ever seen him
shoot and we're playing in a major it
was the regions in Alabama and he'd shot
the two worst days i've ever seen
anybody shoot I mean just he just
couldn't it was just whatever it was and
of course it was I'm a shitty caddy and
you know miss shittiest caddy ever and
then the last day like we're there the
third day he shot decent then the last
day I'll tell you at the end of the day
he shot he shot seven under the last day
wow so but it was like we were on he'd
been playing well all day and it was a
Sunday on Sunday we were playing a while
all dance Sunday and it was like you
know he just kept like [ __ ] you would
always like say you know I always wanted
to hit way more like he would hit one
hit a pitching wedge 160 yards and
accuse it wit can though yeah but
there's no reason to there's no there's
no reason to hit it that far and I
remember we're on the 17th hole which
was this par 3 and and we played it you
know two days we played it that three
days before and there was this number
and it was this in this claw be too hit
too far you know so it was a perfect
nine iron it was a perfect nine iron
that's all I had to do just hit a
[ __ ] nine iron and he kept saying
like you know and there's water in front
there's bunker I mean there's just all
kinds of trouble all you have to do is
hit a 9-iron and it slopes from back to
front the whole thing so anything short
of the pin goes in the water anything
right or longos is dead you know so just
hit it in the [ __ ] center of the
green and it will roll
to the pin and so he kept it kept
arguing with me and identity box on the
tee box he kept saying I don't think
it's this and I just go just hit the
[ __ ] 9-iron it's perfect Club and
we're playing with Tom kite in Tom kite
just kind of like looks around like is
this like one of those things like I
didn't just hear that like how does that
guy get away with likes it you know my
caddie said that you yeah yeah and any
hits it to a foot it's a nine hour to
avoid he listened and tapped in you know
but he didn't say you know how to go
that was the right oh that right that
was the perfect Club yeah you know he
literally literally was the perfect Club
and it's just one of those things were
and then he fired me and then he hired
me back in August and you know it was
like and we finished the year but you
know I meaning in golf yeah they have to
have a huge ego or just be super
confident there's the guy think yeah
there's guys out there that are like I
mean you know it's funny I mean there's
just stays wit it's a weird sport it's a
weird support you know their skies the
nicest guys in the world Rickie Fowler
jordan Spieth you know just some of
these young guys are the nicest guys in
the world there's such sweethearts and
then of these guys that are just huge
dicks you know that are out there like
anything anything yeah NASCAR comedy com
laughing really so comedy I didn't know
so yeah you used to host the Playboy
morning radio show I did I did the
morning show on Playboy Radio when they
first launched on serious it was before
siriusxm merge so I I also that hosted
it for a year out and we're Glendale
yeah that shitty little thing in
glendale and yeah i got fired yeah i got
fired for what I didn't have tits they
wanted day I did it the first year but I
mean I gotta be honest with you dude it
was like we were live on the east coast
so we're at 7am live so we started at
4am damn thing so but we would come on
after like this we would come on after
the porn like you know the chicks like
and it was like I mean it was so gross
because they had like I mean there's
like dildos everywhere and it was like
come on a meal this guy being this guy
Kevin Kline who's great it now and still
does
doesn't know he does a more he does the
morning show in San Francisco that's
right that's right but um we it was it
was the first year was great it was me
and Kevin we had a [ __ ] blast yeah I
mean we cigar the Playboy Mansion all
the time we would interview half real oh
dude Lisa co Kendra it was when the
girls next door was going on so we would
go do the playboy pics with Kendra we do
the playboy football pics with Kendra
and and then we dinner and we get half's
opinion whatever it was really funny too
because like meetings until he's an old
dude I mean he was an old dude then yeah
but um he was we used to go there and
we'd have to get him before his like
dentures you mean his dentures would
start popping after a while like like
you know an old guys teeth but it's
working yeah I'm you know he'd heard
start popping his to go put some more
that Paula Deen yeah yeah yeah he'd have
to glue it in time and I don't I did it
in yet you know but yeah we got to go to
playboy mansion parties which was
[ __ ] awesome I mean how often were
those there were there were three good
ones a year there was midsummer nights
where was I could've gone Midsummer
Night's was good Halloween's the best
was like a great party Midsummer Night's
was the best because it was just like I
mean it was just is naked I mean I is
everyone naked everywhere just pretty
much pretty much and the good thing was
back then um you know this is like going
back to 2005 so this is 10 11 years ago
and back then you know playboy still had
money they still were around they were
still relevant you know so not
completely but I mean they were they
were relevant and you know the show was
hugely popular so everybody knew playboy
was and he would go on this show you
would you would go there and it was
still Hef's parties so you know play
what was spending you know seven hundred
thousand dollars on a party so they had
the whole backyard tented and they have
like you know three 6 mafia was playing
and it was like you know it was crazy
and there would be like 1500 girls and
like 600 guys she's and so a lot of
people and you never got like I mean if
you were invited you had to be invited
yeah there was no like you didn't you
couldn't pay to go so you had to be
invited so it's kind of like if you were
a dude and you were they
you kind of got this check by your name
like okay well he's he's somebody so I
mean it's like you know getting a blow
job by the monkey cages was not really a
big deal you know that happened I was
standard procedure they had condoms in
the nose monkey cages feeding the
monkeys but not get my dick yeah they
had they had condoms in the little
refrigerators at the tennis courts I
mean it was like yeah [ __ ] was going on
there man yeah I mean you wouldn't go i
mean the grotto was like gross I mean
that was for like that was for like
orange county you know you didn't go in
the grotto that was disgusting you think
we could get pregnant in the grotto yeah
it was usually it was usually just two
chicks like going down on each other in
the grotto that's usually what it was
because it was so it was like hot and
steamy in there it's like a big hot tub
that had a roof i'm going there and
you're like oh this doesn't smell right
ya know and it looks good but it doesn't
smell right so you go in there you kind
of peek your head and you're like oh
yeah yeah that's what's going on yeah
that's what's going on but half it go to
bed about two thirty you know he'd go to
bed and then the roush it would get wild
because it would just go off you know to
like 430-5 in the morning there it was
just like then the clothes have come off
and it wouldn't be in the pool and it
was [ __ ] awesome it was great sanity
and you were sober yeah but it didn't
matter now and I was like I just could
stay up later than everybody else you
know it was it was so much fun it would
really was it's kind of like people go
was the playboy mansion parties
everything that you thought they'd be
and it's like that in more you know that
was it was everything he thought it was
you know I'd like to go just toilet
property be honest with you I'm like 20
acres is it like a radar looks like five
yeah it's not that I cake you know big
five acres in the middle Beverly Hills
yes that's not it's not not crawling a
state you know it's not it's not that
it's not it's big it's contact yeah it's
kind of compact the house is kind of
run-down you know it's not really this
way when I went for I went to an SP
after party yeah yeah and they it was
big enough that they had the monkey cage
and everything all in the back where you
courts talking about but then they had a
boxing ring that they did Friday Night
Fights fly I'm the Playboy Mansion so we
got to watch a real fight that was an
HBO fight and so then there was plenty
room for all these people around and the
pulls over here and all that stuff yeah
I mean they he's the only guy that still
has a fireworks license so he actually
on fourth of July he has a firework show
at the front of Playboy Mansion in the
middle of [ __ ] Beverly Hills he
[ __ ] has it I've been the fourth of
july party spin so if you just pull up
out on the street you'll see that [ __ ]
going o absa well yeah you can't really
you have it's probably probably better
off being on the golf course because his
his backyard backs up to la Country Club
oh yeah Ellie North I mean I'll tell you
one time we were before I had ever done
Playboy fries I remember one time this
when he was married and he had you know
his married had kids there was like a
15-year period where there was no
parties there he was married to that
girl Kim and you know they had the kids
and everything I remember what time we
heard all this little noises giggling
and stuff going on and we climbed on top
on the golf cart so look over the fence
and it was like a kid's birthday party I
was hoping like fine young naked chicks
like titties bouncing around on
trampolines and I turn owners like a
clown making balloons for kids party I'm
like that's [ __ ] disappoint this is
where my life is that I'm more concerned
about like hygiene la north yeah I know
but uh yeah but I mean there been some
good parties I went to his 80th birthday
party that was that was awesome I mean
it'sit's they're really fun now it's
kind of run by you know it's you it's a
pay you can pay to go to playboy party
know it's expensive but you can pay to
go yeah and it's just kind of like it's
kind of skanky now yeah I'm kind of
psycho kind of saw it go downhill a
little bit but I mean now there's not
even nudity and playboy that's true
there is no get out we live in a world
no no they don t like GQ or something
like that I don't know when I Maxim I
don't know it's not good though it's not
good I mean I did I did nine years of
the Playboy comedy tour in Las Vegas and
I got to see a lot of playmates and I
got to tell you if you're taking the
nudity out you might as well just throw
them to the side there there's not a lot
of depth well I i I've said before the
women i saw that were groupies for the
athletes were ten times better than any
of the bunnies or playmates that were
walking around that place there's a
handful body makeup all over
[ __ ] yeah I certainly there's a handful
that are you're like I there's a handful
there's like that there's the kara
Monaco is the Allison weights I mean
that our Miss February's they're just
unbelievable hot still to this day like
you go oh my god unfucking real but um
most the time you're like no I don't
know yeah you got to put some makeup on
it's not that not that good not that
nice you got a professional airbrush
sure when you're walking in there yeah
well can you do you know what you're
gonna do well we're out of time and this
has been a lot of fun man thank you for
coming on thank you for sharing great
guys stories like five lot yeah you
really have I'm hoping for seven I know
well you got by on one in Vegas it
definitely did you can someone's off the
list went off the list we might have six
left that thanks guys for having a
[ __ ] you guys are the best yeah man
was great oh man thank you will you one
more time just plug whatever you'd like
um you can best thing to just go to my
website court McCown com cor tmcc Oh
wn.com and go download the album yeah
you can download the album there's my
Instagram on their Twitter and all that
stuff I mean I probably have I think I
have 400 Twitter followers now so I'm
really good to be getting up there yeah
that's nice I'm getting up there you
know nobody gives a [ __ ] what I have to
say I really no I mean it's like I mean
what do I tweet up you know tweet a
picture my meal my [ __ ] Metamucil I'm
talking taken time because I stirred as
I stirred in the glass like it like you
do at 51 I'll duhamel yeah I would too
is that the secret ya know a secret is
to smoke a pack a day yeah figured
Harry's I'm like that so I do and it's
bad but you know what you gonna do
thanks for coming on buddy that's great
see you great to have you guys as always
Jay Larson calm be calm Jay Larson
comedy on all social media Ryan Sickler
on Twitter Instagram Facebook Ryan
Sickler calm will talk to you all next
Tuesday